Oh, good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday. As you might notice, I'm here in my new office
and I'm walking on my treadmill desk
Why did I get a treadmill desk? Well, two reasons, Hank
First, I am a nerd and I heard that you could level up in your nerdiness by getting a treadmill desk
So I was like, 'alright'
To talk about the second reason, we need to go back in time to Memorial Day weekend
when you and I went to the beach together
Now Hank, you may remember that we ran into the ocean, both wearing our shirts
to protect the public, and then we had an old-fashioned noodle war
you know, like people in their thirties do
and in that noodle war, it was widely reported that you won
but in fact, you did not win, because as you can see right here, you abandoned your noodle
which is losing! Anybody who abandons their noodle has lost the noodle war!
That's the rules!
So just to be perfectly clear, I won the noodle war
However, after I won the noodle war, you picked me up and slammed me into the water
and at some point when you were lifting this nearly 200 pound mass and then slamming it into the water,
I thought to myself, 'Hank has gotten kind of fit lately'
And Hank, it turns out that over the last several months, you've quietly been doing this exercise regimen
that has resulted in you becoming kind of buff
In fact, several people commented about it on your last video
Now, I didn't get this treadmill desk just because you got fit and I'm jealous
But I'm not gonna deny it Hank, I was partly inspired by my Memorial Day dunking.
Also, third reason: Hank, as you know, I am obsessed in all the ways that in trying to save ourselves we kill ourselves,
Like all the the ways we act irrationally about health.
For instance, I'm a big fan of hand sanitizer, but sometimes I use hand sanitizer while I'm driving.
And that's not rational, because I'm creating more risks for myself by using the hand sanitizer than I would if I just drove.
Anyway, Hank, it turns out that people that sit more than eleven hours a day are twice as likely to die from all causes over the next 15 years than people that sit for less than four hours a day.
Well, Hank, I don't need to tell you why this is a concern to me.
I live on the internet, the world capital of sitting.
Initially, I thought it might not be a problem because I usually don't sit...
... I recline.
But it turns out reclining count as sitting.
Sitting too much increase your risks of like heart attack, diabetes, certain types of cancer...
So I was like, I'm not gonna do it anymore Hank, I'm gonna be a stander!
I'm gonna be a stander and a walker!
My entire new novel is gonna be written while walking.
Or this will end up like all the other fitness crap in my basement.
Hank, DFTBA, congratulations on your new found... you know.
I'll see you on Friday.
Alright Hank, I'm happy, so I'm gonna try this.
Don't try this at home.
YESSS!